[Music]
my name is William Falcon I am a PhD
student at NYU and Facebook I research
so I'm working on unsupervised
representation learning which means
basically trying to devise some sort of
learning technique to try to extract
more information from data without
labels so that you can use this for like
downstream tasks and get better accuracy
or whatever you're trying to do so this
is an active field of research so what
I'm showing you is basically us bridging
the gap between on supervised
unsupervised learning or like getting
closer we're not quite there yet but
I'll show you where the gaps are so if
you wanted to apply as an industry what
you could take right now I mean bird
it's like pretty popular most people
know that but that's one instantiation
of this so today I'm going to talk about
the difference between these three
concepts there's some supervised
learning self supervised okay there's
some supervised learning self supervised
learning and self supervised sorry don't
supervise self supervised supervised
there's active learning there's
semi-supervised there's these other
things which I'll kind of cover a bit
but it mostly has to do with how many
labels you're using or yeah next I'm
going to tell you why we don't want to
be doing supervised learning generally
this is more like a kind of existential
reason costs of supervised learning so
this is more I'm trying to tie it more
through like why why would this cost use
a company a lot of money
I mean you I think most people know the
reason
and then theoretical approaches so I'm
gonna do a little bit literature review
and then I'll go into kind of the mains
to state-of-the-art methods and then
going through my own work which we're
publishing this week and our results are
like how that works
and then cover the current state of the
art so again the things that we're
working on are general methods that can
apply across computer vision natural
language processing they're more like
theoretical developments but we test a
lot of them in computer vision because
it's easier to understand how they work
but you could extract you could
extrapolate those two and
P and then some closing thoughts just
like a very quick summary okay so the
main differences unsupervised supervised
and self supervised learning okay so I
want to take a vote so justjust people
you can just shout what you think this
is just tell me what what is this data
point what is it dog okay what about now
it's a what dancing dog okay anyone had
something different
yeah child in a costume I could see that
like a toddler yeah what else a begging
dog okay cute dog yeah that's like the
first one that people say cutest thing
ever right and then you have dog then
you have dancing dog pet in the living
room so I went around fair and took a
survey and this is what people said pet
on the floor dog evolving so the point
is that humans are biased right so when
we're labeling data we're embedding
those biases into that so when you have
labeled data and you're running through
systems you're bringing that in
implicitly which means that you are not
necessarily going to extract the
relevant information maybe for your task
you think you need the class of the
object to solve that problem but in fact
you don't maybe you need the relative
relationship of how the objects interact
with each other or how physics place our
role into into the task right but you
won't know that if you're labeling data
on your own so this is like the
existential part why we want to
generally move away from supervised
learning so one thing that people know
about I guess is transfer learning and
I'll just motivate what this means so so
why do we care about a good
representation
you know before I before I came to NYU
us here at Columbia do a neuroscience
research and we were basically looking
at neural activity in the brain and the
retina and then reconstructing things
like images or maybe movements from that
stuff
however you know when we were when we
were collecting this data it's really
expensive so we would have to wait for
like an animal to either pass away or
something
and then measured some neural activity
for like an hour and then that's all you
had maybe that happened every three
months and so we would flash image that
unlike monkey retina and then capture
the neural activity and then reconstruct
that image later on so that's somewhere
we'll be presented at nips
sorry Europe's a few few years ago and
the problem is that you know I only have
maybe like 2000 samples of that so I
can't really do that well unless I have
a really good prior model which is a
representation extractor another case is
medical imaging so you want to do cancer
detection there not a lot of those
images and so you would need a really
strong model something like a vgg net
pre-trained an image that which you
would use to extract features and then
do some classification on and
self-driving cars so another thing here
is you know a good example is you see
you see kids here or whatever but in the
real world a helicopter might fly
through there so that's your data it's
not going to capture that information if
this is what you're looking for humans
and those kind of labels so you also
need a way to model this kind of like
uncertainty about the world so what is
it cost to this right I mean the first
thing is obviously there's an accuracy
cost so if you have supervised learning
versus weekly supervised or unsupervised
learning
you basically this is kind of the curve
in terms of how much is going to cost
you to get these labels right so right
now you can get really good accuracy but
it's gonna cost you a lot of money to
get these labels on supervised learning
there's a ton of unlabeled data in the
world so what we want to do is shift
that and basically say cool if we could
extract better representations we'd be
able to use all of the videos in the
world all of the images to extract all
the meaningful information so this is
generally what we're going to move
there's a big economical impact as well
for companies so unsupervised learning
versus self supervised learning in self
supervised learning you this is one
example this is something called
colorful image colorization so you have
a an image that you desaturate and you
just turn into gray and white sorry
black and white and your tasks is to
basically come up with some model that
puts that color back into the image
right
so this is so called self supervised
learning because you're taking something
in your input and trying to predict a
different part of it so you could chop
this image in half in this case you're
taking the color channels and trying to
predict the other color channels from
from the non-existing color channels
this work is about solving a jigsaw
puzzle so let's say you take this a
picture of this tiger I guess I don't
know what this is and you you overlay
this kind of grid of you know like a
jigsaw game and then the task is you
basically shuffle these and you try to
get your neural network to solve that
task and so this kind of works okay but
again two things that I want you to
notice is that you have to know that
you're dealing with images to do any of
these things right this won't generalize
to an LP
because I can't jigsaw a word for
example so you need a lot of domain
knowledge so these things rely a lot on
the data or mentation stuff not
necessarily in the learning algorithm so
we want to build intelligent systems
that generalize well we don't want them
to take information from that specific
domain or need information from that
specific domain to solve the task the
third kind of work is very related so
this one you have some context and here
you might have a photo of a cat and you
basically randomly pick two patches out
of that and you say well here's a
question and you have two questions at
the bottom it's basically like an
analogy you would say well in this in
question one you know the wheel what's a
what's a relative relationship between
the wheel and the express symbol there
when I'm giving you this cat so would
that match to like an ear and a nose
could you solve that task so this is
okay all of this work is from like
2016-2017 so a few years ago and this
one is about predicting image rotations
so you take an image you rotate it and
then you have a soft max over the angles
that you rotate it so you could have 45
90 whatever and then you try to predict
which one it was again all of this stuff
is very specific to images so it's not
something that we want to be kind of
moving forward with
so now to just kind of highlight the
point that these things should be
general across domains do we have Bert
right so Bert is another instance of
representational learning where you have
this mask word prediction task and then
you have this next sentence prediction
task right so I love AI because it's
crazy that it works so this these two
tasks define kind of the the Bert
training model but again this is a bit
domain-specific you need sentences you
need to be predicting that the next
sentence although our guys kind of
general because I could think about this
as a video as well or sound sequence I'd
be the same concept where I would mask
parts of it try to predict the other
parts from the context or try to predict
the sequence from the previous sequence
so I think everyone's aware but Bert's
kind of well there's a bunch of other
work on top of it now but transformer
based networks are the state of the art
right now for NLP transfer learning and
you can see that whatever the tests are
you doing under the hood sorry whatever
the representation that you're learning
under the hood allows you to fine-tune a
very tiny data set and get really high
accuracy this is another work this is
unsupervised machine translation a lot
of this is from fair and also my advisor
at NYU so what you do basically is you
this purple and blue they're like
languages basically sorry we'll do this
animation again okay so on the left on
the right you have purple and blue you
could be like Spanish and English and in
the red in the middle you have this like
latent language that you don't know what
it is and what you're basically doing is
you're saying cool if I can rotate these
two languages into a single shared space
and I know some other words map then I'm
going to assume that the other mappings
will work so in this case you have got o
uncut and then in the other language in
that space you'll be able to just pull
out that like that vector around that
that kind of like location and latent
space and that normally gives you like
the translation so this is unsupervised
translation meaning I don't need to have
like so many examples of a sentence
matching the other sentence right so
they do a really cool job
this is 2017 as well
they've they've expanded a lot more now
but you could think about this like the
implications of this are really
interesting because you could take
something like a language you know there
are a lot of countries in either Africa
or Latin America where you have a lot of
natives and they have different dialects
and think so we'll never be translated
so you can think about this as a way to
to do that to bridge that gap you maybe
take a few texts that they have and
you're able to do this on supervised
translation part so I'm explaining these
things because I want you guys to think
about I guess all of this and like very
abstract terms like I said this happens
to be text but you could think about
this as sound you can think about this
as images videos whatever you want just
the core idea so it's important so again
why is this bad well I already motivated
the first reason which is we need too
much information too much domain
expertise to solve the task but you know
I'm coming at it from a neuroscience
perspective as well and you know a lot
like we want to motivate a lot of our
work at least in my lab through how we
think humans learn and so you know when
you're an infant the kind of main thing
is let's say that sorry so when you're
an infant and you kind of develop your
sense of sense of vision the first thing
you see is just a bunch of blurry pixels
you don't you don't see any shapes or
anything as s the time goes on you start
at you start sharpening those pixels
into actual objects you start clustering
them into out objects you add color back
in and then eventually have a for clear
full clear picture so one of the things
that motivates kind of our research is
if this move if this blurry image never
moved it would be really hard to
separate what objects closer to what so
one thing that we're looking at as
videos right so humans like we really
should be looking at some sort of
sequence so that we can track
information over time how motion changes
through doing that sorry let me see yeah
so they're doing that we're able to
extract things like you know maybe
humans what you know there's physics
involved if they hit a ball the ball
isn't going to disappear it's going to
be pushed away if they eat something it
might disappear so there are all these
relationships that are not encoded in
any kind of labels that we want to be
extracting this is really useful for
something like self-driving cars
where you want you might want to predict
the physics trajectory of an object or
or your car itself so you can extract
things like intuitive physics from here
object permanence those kind of tests so
this I think everyone's super familiar
with this and this is basically an
analogy for the bits of information so a
label mostly carries the number of
classes as a bits of information that
you can use to learn from right so
that's supervised learning the icing on
the cake and then and you know the the
cherry at the top basically for
reinforcement learning just means that
you get a scalar reward after running
some really long trial like you play a
game for like two minutes and then you
get a score that's the only information
that you're getting things have gotten
more more interesting where you get you
can extract more information but at the
end of the day you have a trajectory
where that reward basically summarizes
what happened so it's very very little
bit little information however an
unsupervised learning self supervised
predictive you have all of information
in the image you have the way that the
objects separate from each other how
they interact the colors so much
information that we can take advantage
of so unsupervised learning here are so
that was self supervised learning so
here sorry an MT should have been in
this section as well but so when people
think about unsupervised learning maybe
the first model to think about is this
auto-encoder model so you have some
inputs you run it through some model and
then you try to reconstruct that input
right so normally you would modify the
input somehow either you add noise you
chop parts of it off you remove some
something that makes it not easy to
reconstruct and then you have some sort
of latent space that encodes some some
some latent virus that you can use to
basically reconstruct that image and
hopefully they can give you things like
this entanglement right so there's an
Nvidia paper where they could take one
of these latent variables and kind of
interpolate in that latent space and it
would change the color of the street of
the reconstructed image because they
were able to disentangle that part of it
so you could imagine you have a hundred
of these latent states and if I were to
change one of them the eyes of this frog
which
and if I change the right combination
perhaps the face of the Frog changes
something else and so this is a kind of
this entanglement that we want to be
doing under the hood and you know these
feral theories that we think that maybe
to do to actually build intelligent
systems humans to disentangle
information could be wrong maybe we
don't actually need it but right now
that's what we believe
I think everyone's familiar with Ganz as
well so you know you have an image you
have some generator that makes a fake
image and basically the the task is to
have some other neural network decide
whether the real image is actually a
real image or the fake image is a fake
image right and so you have this kind of
like game theory game and then through
that you have you reach this equilibrium
where the generator should learn to
match the distribution of real images
and so you can generate arbitrarily
complex images that that appear to be
from the same distribution and the
discriminator should be very good at
distinguishing something fake or not but
at the end it should be very confused
because if if your generator is good
enough then the discriminator will be
tricked all the time and so the point of
this is that people have tried to use
this for representation learning so the
generator then they might use the
generator to run an image through it and
then extract that feature map at the end
and then use it for like classification
in some downstream tasks it turns out to
not work that well I'll same for
auto-encoders so you would take an image
take that latent state sorry take the
latent state and use that to classify
something downrange okay so this is the
first now we're getting to our research
so this this is a first work that I'll
explain it's learning representations by
maximizing mutual information across
views views sorry this is from Mila so
yoshua bengio slab and MSR Microsoft
Research and you have this image and
basically it's like a four-stage process
right so you you take this image you run
it through the state augmentation
pipeline and the pipeline gives you two
versions of the same image it's some
supervisors we do have labels so while
we're doing this is because what we're
saying is hey let's assume that
image is its own class like we don't
know how many classes are but we know
that that image has to belong to a class
because it is an image so we're gonna
say it is its own class now we're going
to somehow sample two versions of that
now we have two two samples from the
same class right so we have this frog
even though it's augmentations we have
this like upside down green frog and
then we have this kind of blurry version
of the Frog the actual applications are
more complicated than this but the
general idea is you take a single image
that represents a class and you sample
two versions of that class by
transforming that image so now we have
what you would call a label like I can
say well cool I know that this image
that these two samples should be close
together like we want them to say that
there's this should be as similar as
possible so you take that you take each
one of these guys and you run them
through a convolutional network that's
gonna give you three feature Maps so
normally everyone works and just like
that last feature map in this case we're
taking three feature maps and there's
the CNN normally so residual network and
then we use the same network to run the
other image and extract those three
feature Maps right so now we have for
each image remember these feature maps
represent that image so three feature
maps that describe what this image is
about this is where the across views
part comes in so they're saying across
views means the the kind of abstractions
from F 1 F 2 and F 3 F 3 summarizes
moreover the image F 2 less of like it's
more local and F 1 is much more local so
what they do now is something called
negative sampling but the first thing
they do is they sample a single vector
from sorry
so they sample a single vector from that
F 3 of the first image and they compare
against all of the vectors in F 2 so
these are tensors rights with this the
dimensions here for each one of these
guys is badge by by row by heights by
depth and so you can think about the row
and height as a number of vectors and
the depth as a dimension of that vector
and so you would pick basically an ion
Ju sample randomly pick one of those
vectors so if you had 64 channels that
vector have 64 dimensions and then on F
2 you would take all of those and then
you compute a dot product between all of
them
and you call those your positive scores
so they do this task across three
different feature Maps so they take the
last feature map against the previous
two of the other image and then across
the the middle tube and then they
minimize the softmax of this so what
you're seeing here against for this one
image but if you normally have a batch
of theta so now because you assume that
every single image is its own class in
that batch you're gonna take every other
image that is not this image that we're
looking at and you're gonna say they're
from a different class even though there
might be a few collisions from that same
class you're just gonna ignore that and
you say all of these other images are
from different classes and so now you
have these comparisons this dot product
between F 3 and F 2 gives you a positive
score that you want to maximize and then
the the dot product between F 3 red here
and like let's say a blue from a
separate image you would have minimize
that score and so you can put this into
a soft Max and that's called contrast
nce loss I forget the what NC stands for
but it basically learns to say ok well
push things together that are from that
are similar and push everything else far
apart and then you do this by
directional thing so you do it the other
way as well
so that's that's am dim that's the first
kind of work that we're comparing this
is something from deep mind this is
called CPC contrasted predictive coding
and the way this works is kind of the
same thing so you have the state
augmentation pipeline you have an image
but instead of splitting into two images
they split it into patches right
and so they calculate these overlapping
patches and you can think about each one
of these patches again as representing a
version of an image from that class of
images right so Peretz there are nine
pairs here but it's really just a one so
you take those patches you run him
through the encoder and you get this Z
tensor right so in this case you had
nine patches the Z would be three by
three by number of channels that you
have there and then on the right you
have the super-complicated prediction
task which is we find to be not
necessary once we we like look through
our framework so I'll explain this I'm
sorry for the for the naming but this is
what the the use in their paper and also
deep mind doesn't really share codes so
I spend a lot of time in
menteng this anyways so you have to Z
remember the Z is a vector that's three
by three in this case and sorry it's a
tensor it's a three by three tensor with
so many dimensions and this black part
of it sorry can I move here no I can't
okay there's just like a little black
square and that's Z at the top that's
like a context window so you could think
about this as a convolution so a single
convolution over those vectors and
that's going to give you a summary it's
going to give you a single point that
summarizes all of those six vectors
that's that blue output it's applying
that convolution overall disease
combination so you get another tensor
that's basically a summarized contextual
version of all the z vectors
okay so there's context encoder that
convolution that we applied it's a
different neural network and now you're
gonna say okay so I have let's say that
you treat the image as kind of time that
at the top left you have time zero and
at the bottom right you have time n so
you're just gonna think about this as
some sort of like time sequence and
you're gonna say okay at time zero so
top left corner I'm gonna take that C
that corresponds to that I'm gonna try
to predict something at like time N or
something built way below that that
specific patch and the way you do that
prediction is you take the C you
multiplied by a weight matrix at that
row that you're trying to predict so
you're saying oh I want to predict the
time and then you take a W matrix at
time n you multiply by you see and then
now you have a label right because that
what that multiplication WC gives you
like your X and then the actual Z from
the bottom of the left it's gonna give
you the label what you were trying to
predict and so now you're basically just
minimizing that distance
so that's CP see it's a little bit
confusing I know I'm sorry but
implementation wise these w.zahn the
right they're actually a list of
matrices so it's just like a bunch of
linear layers and anyway so why we're
going through all this trouble because
we want to learn again representations
and we think that this is one good way
to do this this particular method
constructed with coding is motivated by
neuroscience as well something that we
do which is called predictive coding
they loosely tie it to that you know a
lot of these things are like very
loosely inspired near so
and then then they become engineering
challenges okay so this is our work this
is what we're introducing in a few days
so basically what I just showed you is
kind of confusing and there like a lot
of ways of doing this right and so we
looked at all this work and basically
try to figure out what are they all
really doing and what's really driving
their performance and we basically came
up with the framework that you can
summarize any algorithm that students of
supervised learning into five steps so
in this case you have some sort of data
which is your X that data is only
labeled so that's number one that's like
the first requirement for this framework
the second requirement is so you have
some data augmentation pipeline this is
a of X in am dim that was splitting the
two images in CPC that was creating the
patches great and then and then you have
on the right you have this on that
number two you have an encoder so now
you have the third ingredient your in
this framework is that you have some way
to encode either of those
transformations that you did and extract
features out of it then number four it's
just a PN sampling that we're talking
about so AM dim had that weird like F 3
to F to F 2 to F 2 F 3 to F 1 sampling
strategy CPC basically did it through
that C&Z Network is the same thing we're
just generalizing that and saying well
once you have these positive anchor and
negative features you want to somehow
relate them right so the anchor and the
positive where the two things from the
same image and the negative was all the
other images that are not or the
features from the all the other images
so so we generalized it to that and then
the fifth ingredient is a loss function
you can do anything metric learning but
it turns out that the softmax works the
best nce loss so the more negative
samples you have the better that these
tend to do so
after analyzing all of that we basically
understood kind of where the some of the
issues that these algorithms were having
and we introduced our own version of
these so it's called patch Tim so patch
Tim basically takes the augmentation of
I am dim which is you take an image get
two versions of that image and then
applies the one from CPC on top of it
where you patch it up right so it's just
the to augment ation pipelines put
together
but now we can simplify everything else
everything else is super simple so now
you take an encoder you encode these
patches and then you just have to
feature Maps one for the top image one
for the bottom image and our sampling is
very straightforward you pick one vector
from image x1 and then all of the other
vectors from image x2 you do dot product
compute the scores you want to maximize
the sum of those and then you you take a
different image and you do the same
thing but you want to minimize the dot
product between those so our strategy is
a lot simpler so basically what we find
so here I just went to summarize the
kind of big high level IDs where we're
that we're like the algorithms differ
because if you read these papers it
would seem like they're all doing very
different things but they're all doing
the same thing so where do they differ
that that dot product that I mentioned
that that can be generalized to like a
similarity function some kernel
everyone's using that product but you
could use something else you can use
correlation you could use whatever just
some way to relate those two vectors
together the encoder for all of us we
use rest nuts
however a.m. dim specifically does not
work well with any other rest net and we
found that through our experimentation
our method fixes that problem so you're
able to use any kind of rest net which
is good because there's so many moving
parts the last thing you want to be
doing is trying to figure out how many
layers or like what the width or depth
of this thing should be so you can just
take any any arbitrary like rest and 50
100 whatever the loss everyone's using
nce
the only difference is CPC has like
three sums of C of NCE loss instead of
just the one which is f3 f2 f2 f2 f3 and
f1 each one of those who son and see you
loss and then de documentation pipeline
just summarize how we do it so named dim
you get x1 and x2 out of a of X which is
the two images the two images sampled
from documentation of X CPC you only
have that one and then in ours again you
have two versions how you draw the
anchor positive and negative features is
this way so in am dim you have you just
from that encoding sorry from that
feature map you pick one single vector
that's our a for CPC you do this
projection with W
wkc I and then the plus case because
you're going forward in time so K time
steps and then at the J spot on the
columns and then you try to predict the
the Z vector which just that red that
red guy at the off side by K so it's the
same at the same index changes across
the two different maps and that's your
anchor feature and then 4hours is very
simply just sample that one vector from
that feature map m1 I want for you the
other details but basically positive
features are sums and then negative
features are sums across all of the
other images so main takeaway is from
this the in a batch you have a single
image you try to you assume that that
image comes from a class and you
generate two versions of that image
you're going to calculate the similarity
between those two and say that you want
to make that high and then for every
other image in that batch you're going
to assume they're a different class and
you want to minimize that similarity if
you do though if you do this wrong
you're going to share too much
information between the two images that
are that are the same and you're gonna
learn a trivial solution and you're not
going to learn anything so what we find
yeah sorry
okay cool so the data augmentation
pipeline basically is what we find that
helps does not learn those trivial
solutions so how do we actually do
performance wise the C for 10 sorry the
image net numbers are still running
because it's a very long model or a very
very big model so in C for ten ten
classes 100,000 images they're reported
results are 93 our implementation of
their papers ninety two point once are
pretty close to getting whatever results
say the report we think we're off
because of like the seed or something
and then CPC doesn't actually work that
well in because they only ran the test
on image net so we're finding that it's
not necessarily working super well and
like smaller images however it's very
hard to reproduce our work so there
might be a bug in our implementation
that basically doesn't close that gap
the second and then our results are
we're basically pretty close to am dim
again this is sometimes we get over
sometimes
we get below but this is on average
we're right there just a little bit
below and see for 10 sto 10 same thing
we actually do surpass them on on the
accuracy there sto 10 is an image it's
another data set which is 10 classes but
you're given a hundred thousand
unlabeled images and only five thousand
labelled images and so we're getting
these accuracies again the way that
sorry the way that we're reporting this
is you take that data set CFR 10 you
drop all the labels you pre trained on
that using these methods that I just
explained and then you converge right
you freeze that model and then you add
labels back in slowly in this case we
added all the labels because we're
measuring something called separable ax
t so we want to see how well that
representation this entangles linear
separability and then we add all the
labels back in and then we fine-tune a
1024 unit MLP so it's very tiny
classifier that it's not powerful enough
to solve this task it's just to map the
representation to the classes and we
find that we get these numbers 92 91 an
image tonight we're in the low 60s yeah
so low 60s basically right now it's
continuing to Train so what so what are
the main advantages so we pretty much
have the same performance the first
advantage is that you don't need this
crazy sampling that aimed aim is doing
instead we can just do this which is
just the last to feature maps and we
tested this by doing ablations
so this one two one three two two that's
F 1 F 2 F 3 if these combinations and we
tried different combinations and we see
that a.m. dim really needs that specific
ordering so they're accuracies collapse
when we when when we change the what
we're sampling so it's pretty arbitrary
seems how they picked those arses pretty
robust doesn't matter how you sample
again another advantage that we have is
our network is much better so edit you
can throw any network at this and the
accuracy won't decrease as much we do
find that wider networks do work a lot
better so you increase the filters
instead of 64 - like 3,200 something
like that and they actually tend to do a
lot better so yeah so these are the main
two advantages there are bunch of other
ones I won't cover on here but we have
fewer parameters or network trinks a lot
faster as well
so I mentioned that this stuff is very
expensive to to compute and so okay so
basically how we do this is using this
framework called PI switch lightning
it's a framework that I developed over
the last year mostly I don't why you
unfair and basically what it does is it
allows you to plug your code in and then
get automatic like distributed training
half precision and all this other stuff
so just to illustrate the imagenet model
that's training is right now it's
training on 384 GPUs and it's taken
about 20 days so far it has not
converted yet and these GPUs are V 132
gigs of RAM they're state of the art but
it's sick and a lot of compute to do
this yeah oh these lines are because
sometimes you have to wait for other
jobs because you know other people have
to run stuff too so this is just a me
model but you can imagine we do grid
searches I mean at any one time I might
be running a few thousand GPUs for grid
searches that kind of stuff so well so
what what is the big deal about this as
well is that we lightning addresses the
rubbery disability crisis so this is in
Europe's this is a big conference and
they're using lightning a surficial
framework to to implement a lot of
papers mainly because it works super
well without you having to modify
anything and I'll explain what I mean by
that so this is a lightning module so
you can think about this like a pied
torch module how many people use PI
torch just raise your hands oh wow how
many people use tensorflow tensorflow
how many people have not built any deep
learning anything all right
good yes and try this then so here this
is just a classifier for like imagenet
basically you just sub class this class
lightning module you define your this is
just a single layer network so 28 by 28
image in that image and you have 10
classes the forward is just your forward
pass right so you run the output through
a real ooh and then you get some you
calculate some classification on the
training step is what would go in the
training loop so normally most things
you have to code this training loop or
you have say for badge in data set
sorry for epoch in epochs for badge in
data set and then there's a bunch of
stuff that goes in there
that's really what most people care
about then there's a bunch of stuff
about backward pass optimizer stuff like
mixing
accumulating gradients all this other
stuff training step it's what happens
after for batch in dataset and before
you up you take the optimizer step so
it's really the core of what you care
about and so in this case this is a very
simple model where you just run it
through the forward you get this output
and you run through cross-entropy
you got some laws and then you just send
out laws back into the system and it
does the optimization for you you have
to do anything if you were doing
something like translation you could get
arbitrarily complex on here so this is a
research tool but you can use this for
anything in industry as well I
everything I just showed you I did using
lightning it's all written on here and
it's used to fare a lot as well so on
this training stuff for example if you
were doing translation you would have
like an encoder you encode that then
you'd have a for loop for like beam
search or some sort of decoding so it's
arbitrarily complex so you want to make
it
but for validation step maybe you want
to do something else so here I just did
a loss but in validation maybe I want to
calculate in this case I did loss as
well but I could do accuracy where I
could generate images or I could do
something sample the outputs so it's a
very different part of the training loop
then you pass into what optimizer is you
want to use you could just pass it
multiple if you want it for example for
against and then you define your data
where they're coming from its data
loaders this defines a full system and
this is all the code you need to do to
do to run this stuff on 200 GPUs so how
does this work like if you look on this
you don't see anywhere that I'm calling
CUDA you don't see anywhere that I'm
calling half precision or any of that
I'm not moving data around what happens
is when I sent shade that model I in it
this trainer and I called fit on it and
that's it so if you wanted to specify a
number of GPUs you just set a flag you
say ten GPUs for however any machines
you want and under the hood it launches
all the orchestration stuff for you it
assumes you have a slurm cluster but
we're moving into AWS on a few other
things as well and then what do you get
out of this so literally these three
lines of code and what I just showed you
gives you automatic tensor board you
have to do anything it's already built
in it also gives you automatic training
loop validation checkpointing so it's
gonna tell you what to say the way it's
early stopping and yeah so that's
basically how we do the scaling stuff so
in summary unsupervised is
state-of-the-art in NLP right now so if
you want to do anything with NLP
I would use whatever the latest model is
gptt Oh Bert just look looking a
archived computer vision is lagging
behind in that I mean you can do
transfer learning by using pre trained
models and imagenet but we won't have
the representational power of Bert like
Bert changed everything because a lot of
it is unlabeled like it's unsupervised
that's that's like the main point until
we get to that point in computer vision
we're still going to be lagging behind
once we do though we're gonna unlock new
ways of using our data so you're gonna
be able to do things that I can't even
imagine right now because I'm like in
this limited world of what we know so
far and main takeaways that we need to
move away from images like
domain-specific knowledge and some of
the some of these clever tasks basically
from 2016 to 2017
the research was coming up with some
cool tasks like solving a puzzle or
rotating an image or something it wasn't
on developing an actual learning
algorithm or a method for learning it
was unlike these sort of tasks and again
we find that on the state of the art
methods including our own most of the
games come from the data processing not
learning which is why we're kind of
moving away from that work now because
we just wanted to understand what was
driving the the advancements in that
line of work so that's it thank you
[Music]